[Music]
this guy is an Australian Shepherd we
got her at eight weeks old with the
purpose in mind of turning her into a
search-and-rescue dog a
search-and-rescue dog especially in an
avalanche rescue dog is a dog that's
trained to find human scent that comes
out of the snow so when somebody gets
buried in an avalanche the dog is there
to find that bit of scent is coming out
so that we can locate that person what
she's doing is she's going through the
area and looking before that set and
then when she comes across it she
sources it and let you know about it and
that's that sourcing and communication
that is really the key difference
between a search dog and just any other
animal we got a call on Christmas Eve a
couple of years ago that any Coast
Guardsman had gone missing from Air
Station Kodiak they needed some dogs to
come down and help and we flew down on
Christmas Day and got down to Kodiak
where the weather is always horrendous
it happened to be a beautiful beautiful
day and we went up into the mountains
and found our subject and got him back
to his family before Christmas was over
it really is a 24/7 thing for she and I
we're out in the mountains a lot it's
part of who she is as well
our job now is to keep her happy and
healthy for the rest of her life she's
contributed her whole life so we're
gonna help her have a good time nice to
Earth's skies a rock star man and she
really is she's got a lot of style she
likes to she likes it to be done with
style and she's just really a lot of fun
into her
[Music]
you
[Music]